chantal hébert michelle sy au jai alai
castonguay
bonsoir à vous on voit tout de suite
écouter le premier ministre qui
réagissait comme tout toute la classe
politique à ses petits chiffres gervais
lui et je les rappelle 0,5 en bas donc
du trimestre négatif donc officiellement
techniquement de récession les voici les
chiffres
et voici le premier ministre les faits
indiquent selon la banque du canada
quand on a une contraction de -2 20% de
l'économie canadienne dont l'année
passée au lieu on à la croissance dans d
autres secteurs est aujourd'hui une des
plus forte croissance mensuelle en juin
c'est très rare maintenant que
l'économie canadienne est encore en
croissance ça va continuer selon les
siens le discours reste le reste de
l'année et deux années à venir
alors ce sont des chiffres qui arrêtent
au mode je reviens sur un deuxième
trimestre et monsieur harper dit le
modjo été meilleurs et ce qui s'en vient
juillet ou septembre sera encore
meilleure c'est sa ligne de défense
que voulait-il dire pouvait-il dire
d'autre évidemment la récession qu'on
est en pleine campagne électorale c'est
pour un mot qu'on veut entendre
et est ce qu on est en récession
technique mots des risques que la
croissance revient l'important c'est de
savoir comment les canadiens se sentent
c'est ce qui a un impact sur la campagne
électorale
le dernier sondage abacus montré que 67
% des canadiens se sentent en récession
actuellement qu'elles soient modérés à
graves ou jusqu en dépression et se
terminer parmi les 67 % qui ont
l'impression que l'économie va mal c'est
ce qui a un impact dans la campagne
le terme récession aux contractions on
veut l'utiliser pour l'utiliser c'est un
peu d'importance c'est vraiment il va y
avoir des chiffres sur l'emploi toute
façon venu
oui on va avoir d'autres d'autres
indices économiques d'ici la fin de la
campagne
et pour répondre à votre question et
réponse les wii aurait pu dire d'autre à
nous ce n'est pas qu'en 2011 j'ai passé
toute la campagne adversaires vont mal
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes donc voté
pour moi parce que moi je suis stable il
dit encore oui je dis encore dit à l'ats
s'est dit ce que je vous ai dit au mois
d'avril dans le budget qui était pas
vrai ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
parce que je choisis une forêt le qui
dit on à baisser mois choisi l'arbre le
mois de juin et je vous dis cet art on
va pousser donc occuper vous pas du
regard de la forêt qui va pas mais il
dit ce n'est pas le moment de dépenser
davantage pas de dépenses publiques pas
de défi center qui viennent envoyer des
milliards de dollars de chèques
l'écrivain à toutes les familles au
canada
je me suis français et qui n'ont pas eu
beaucoup d'effet dans les sondages soit
10 impasse
en toute honnêteté avec mesure un peu et
la plupart des banques canadiennes
aujourd'hui induit la reprise avoir une
au troisième trimestre ça va arriver
tout de suite des jardins d'isis la
banque mondiale alors il est bien
possible quelles raisons cela dit c est
là que raison ça change rien si les
canadiens sans que ça va pas bien c'est
les canadiens sans que n'aime pas la
politique économique du gouvernement
harper
c'est pas le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
annonce officiellement qu on est en
récession technique report a dit va
changer cette vision là qu'une qualité
soyons plus spécifique pour les régions
du pays
au québec c'est moins pire que l'alberta
disons le comme ça ce que je commence
toujours par oasis est certainement
moins pire que d'avoir une jambe et un
bras cassé en alberta
c'est ça coule à pic au niveau chrono ça
joue ce contexte économique
c'est difficile à dire parce que les
albertains ont déjà pris une chance en
allant vers le npd au mondial c'est pas
certain qu'ils vont dire je vais prendre
un gouvernement qui est dirigé par un
chef qui est pas d'ici qui a pas
beaucoup de racines
au fédéral les chiffres des sondages
indiquent pas ça même si quand on y
regarde de façon plus mis qu il ya des
brèches ici et là mais si monsieur
harper perd son pari électoral
ce sera pas parce que l'alberta la
saskatchewan vont être tournés
massivement contenu comme c'est arrivé
au provincial en alberta et je vais être
parce que l'ontario aura beaucoup changé
de liberté on punit les progressistes
conservateurs parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils nous avaient pas suffisamment
diversifié leurs économique était
victime de la chute du prix du pétrole
l'inquiétude de la peur ce n'est pas que
les albertains fasse la même chose c'est
que les ontariens fasse la même chose
les manitobains fasse la même chose que
le québec fasse la même chose en disant
vous avez tous mis vos oeufs dans le
même panier maintenant on n'a eu besoin
que vous souteniez le secteur
manufacturier
et vous l'avez pas fait si tout le monde
fait ce constat là là ça va mal pour
stephen harper une chose importante
c'est que dans les chiffres de richesse
de récession quand on regarde chacune
des industries au canada le
manufacturier est en récession que
seulement normalement maca dollars
canadiens aussi beau ça devrait aller
super biais pour les factures liées au
québec et en ontario
ce n'est pas le cas alors peut-être pas
encore mais ça c'est une autre histoire
à ce n'est pas le cas actuellement
alors pour mesurer un peu c'est pas
comme s'il faut a dit raul ne savons pas
si pire à quelques autres endroits
prochain rendez vous chiffre de l'emploi
vendredi indicateur qui est plus clair
pour le commun des mortels sont
davantage les gens bien sûr bloc
québécois david gentilles et ce matin
nous apprenait entre soulignait le fait
que le bloc vise 30 trentaine de côté
peut-être - le chef a répondu non non
non bon on ce qu'on entend
habituellement campagne électorale est
un aveu de faiblesse
alec écoutez moi j'étais surpris de voir
le chiffre de 30 compter les chiffres
que j'avais été beaucoup plus boxe moi
je pensais que au bloc québécois ont du
moins jusqu'à récemment on visait de
redevenir un parti officiel à la chambre
des communes pour bénéficier du budget
du temps par ads ça veut dire 12 députés
alors on est en bas du 30 donc pas dit
que depuis on est un peu plus optimiste
est peut-être que je cite les devenu
encore davantage dans les derniers jours
quand en haut de 30 mois ce qui est
certain c'est que tout le prenais alors
barré mois moi j'ai l'impression que le
bloc québécois actuellement six ans
capable d'aller chercher d'autres
circonscriptions vont trouver qui ont
fait une bonne campagne d'entendre ça
commence à être optimiste on voit
ciblées c'est évident des régions
spécifiques on ne fait plus campagne
comme c'est elle connaît les
les précédentes sur sa première fois
c'est la première fois will host à une
campagne de ce type là parce qu'on a
aussi réduit à quatre députés la
dernière fois il en restait 2 au
déclenchement électoraliste une marche à
monter énorme si on veut revenir à 50,9
à l'époque donc je pense que françois
legault sur le bloc bas quand on tombe
bas et ça a été une coque par exemple
des conservateurs c'est c'est pas facile
de remonter à 12,4 les boues joker qui
est des revenus en pleine gueule c'est
le dernier loto à la gilles duceppe qui
a précédé celui ci et de peine et de
misère et s'est rendu à 12 mai mais
d'obtenir deux ans dans tout le canada
alors dans le moment on voit pas dans
les chiffres des sondages
aucun sondage qui accrédite la thèse
même de 10 députés à leurs 12 ce serait
effectivement un grand succès 38 ont de
l'ambition
soyons clairs la route trop à la fin
actuellement quand on regarde les gens
qui font des projections à partir des
sondages actuels c'est zéro siège 1
ça sera peut-être parce a vendu au soir
de l'élection mais qu'elle dit que le
bloc cible c'est pas qu'il ya moins
d'ambition c'est juste qu'il est
réaliste c'est ça mais je vous rappelle
une époque où ils ont obtenu 54 58 ans
et qui a d'abord c'est à dire beaucoup
de bois la terre c'est exactement
chanteuse avait écrit une chronique qui
nous a inspiré le troisième thème de
cette de ce panel fréquemment le vote du
npd et npd jusqu'à une semaine avant le
vote
on l'a vu palmaert est allé chercher le
npd une certaine époque
est ce que monsieur mulcair est assis
sur des bases solides là où on voit
c'est très serré il est certainement sur
des bases inconnu et je vous dis ça je
vais pas aller à paul martin parce que
dans ces temps de paul martin était le
parti d'opposition principale où le
parti qui avait le plus de chances de
battre les conservateurs donc qu'ils
pouvaient battre le rappel des
néo-démocrates la situation est inversée
mais ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est en
2011 quand la vague orange est arrivé au
québec à l'extérieur du québec ça a été
une excellente nouvelle pour les
conservateurs parce que là il ya plein
d'électeurs libéraux un peu plus
conservateur qui se sont dit jack layton
on veut pas ça et qui se sont repliés
sur monsieur reprend là j'ai regardé la
campagne c'était quand même un mois plus
comment il ya pas un sondage qui est pas
montré le mpd en tête des fois de peu
mais néanmoins en tête
il n'y a pas eu ce mouvement l'heure du
tout vers des conservateurs au contraire
les conservateurs sont en déficit en
ontario de 15 points dans le moment à la
moyenne des sondages par rapport à leurs
performances de 2011
idem en colombie-britannique et ses
votes ne sont pas allés à monsieur
wenger
ils vont à justin trudeau mais dans les
faits ce que justin trudeau est en train
de faire c'est affaiblir les
conservateurs et divise ils votent à
droite ump et mais c'est exactement ce
que qu'espéraient les conservateurs
rabattre les voteurs centre droite
libéraux ou ailleurs et les rabat selon
kalpana ce qui n'est pas arrivé ceux qui
n'arrivent pas dans le monde je
n'arrivais pas jusqu'à ce qu'on entende
justin trudeau dire qu'il va faire trois
déficits en 4ème dans les sondages
ont-ils pris la mesure de cet engagement
là qui pour ce qu'on appelle des
libéraux plus bleu donc plus
conservateurs pourraient avoir un impact
et donc se déplacer légèrement vers
stephen harper mais ces briques de
bulles d'eau si possible donc avant que
cette fenêtre s'ouvre pour stephen
harper il n'y avait pas de déplacement
effectivement est ce que maintenant ça
va changer la donne on est encore au
moins une semaine jour une chose
importante aussi l'usure du pouvoir qui
était pas là de la même façon en 2011
et puis les faits bregman et ça va
peut-être cesser les ontariens qui ont
peur du npd parce que le gouvernement
bouchard elle connaît bien longtemps du
moins l'impression que ça va c'est ce
qui s'y trouve
je me dis qu'après véritable fête a
gagné toute interview quand on gagne la
colombie-britannique et le québec
alors il soit aussi qu'il faut regarder
le paquet d'actions solide pour ce cycle
d'un moment les conservateurs sont en
recul partout on parle beaucoup des deux
os mais c'est ce sont eux qui ont le
pouvoir
on se retrouve jeudi et j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un petit bilan sur les sujets
abordés dans cette campagne d'hazare
parler d'économie mais quel genre de
sujets aussi que jean va faire la
manchette et voilà messieurs dames ce
rendez vous on se retrouve demain
messieurs avec emmanuel voilà bonne fin
de journée
en pareil